- How did I come out to my grandmother?
She asked me how many
bedrooms were in the apartment
I shared with my
ex-girlfriend and I said, one.
(upbeat music)
She got it.
Is your family accepting
of having your wife visit
for the holidays?
More like, is my wife accepting
of having my family visit
for the holidays?
'Cause I live with my wife.
Also, my wife is my family.
I'm not out to my
conservative Catholic parents
but I really wanna wear
a tie to Thanksgiving
'cause I've started to really
enjoy dressing androgynously.
Is it a bad idea to dress so
obviously gay around them?
I don't know, I think dressing
obviously gay kinda rules.
Not that straight women don't wear ties.
Diane Keaton.
I'm 35, so I know who that is.
What is your favorite
part about going home
for the holidays?
Pie.
I came out as trans around
this time last year.
Oh hey, congrats.
And although most of my
family is pretty supportive,
they can ask awkward questions sometimes,
specifically about when I'll
be getting certain surgeries.
How can I let them this
is not their business
without bringing down the mood?
Boo!
That's to them, not you.
Listen, that's your bod.
And I assume you don't
ask whoever this is,
cousins, uncles, your mom
and dad about their bod.
Well, I don't know your family.
If you draw a line in the sand
because they're making you uncomfortable,
you are protecting your
mental and emotional safety,
and that's not bringing down the mood.
What do you say when you're a lesbian
but your family keeps asking
why you don't have a boyfriend?
Distraction, bring up a different topic,
something like Obamacare.
Let them debate.
What do I do if I've come
out to my mom five times
and she still ignores the fact
that I've come out to her?
At this point,
you just have to proceed
as if she already knows,
because she already knows.
She's pretending she
doesn't, but she knows.
Just talk to her like you
normally would about your life.
I'm gay and I have family
members who voted for Trump.
How do I not go insane?
Well, nothing brings joy to the holidays
like a really stressful and
nearly devastating election.
So, what do we do now?
You should let your family
know if a Trump presidency
is upsetting to you.
I called my parents before the election,
I told them what was at stake for me,
and actually, they listened.
So, there's hope, it's not too late.
Overall, the holidays should be about
celebration and relaxation.
So, if the family that you were born into
isn't that for you, take a friendsgiving,
or rent some great movies.
Go home and then play
my act for your family.
Play this video, play this
video for your family.